We start this
morning with
some really incredible new video
out of southern Ukraine.
It shows the aftermath
of a purported
Ukrainian attack
on the Russian occupied city of Moloto.
This is one of several explosions
overnight felt in southern Ukraine
and on the Crimean peninsula.
Russian state
media is also reporting missile
strikes in eastern Ukraine
and the self-proclaimed Donetsk
People's Republic.
Now, the attacks come hours
after a barrage of Russian
drone strikes across Ukraine.
And President
Vladimir Zelensky
says five Iranian drones
hit key power facilities around
Odessa Saturday,
knocking out power
to more than one
and a half million people.
CNN's Sam Kiley is live for us
now from Kiev.
Sam, give us an update on
on what all these new developments mean
Well, first of all, the Odessa strikes.
I think the significance there is
that these were made
according to the Ukrainian
Ukrainian government
by the Iranian supplied side drones.
These are Iranian missiles
that are pretty primitive, cheap to make.
But there had been an assumption
by the from the Ukrainians
that they were running low on
or had run out of entirely
these Iranian made drones.
Now, the
they fired some 15 five got through.
They've crippled
temporarily the power supply
to a DSLR, a city of over
a million people
that has largely been spared
a lot of these attacks
on the energy infrastructure here
in Ukraine elsewhere in the country
the power system is coming back to life.
It's down to about 75% of capacity
take a long time to fix it
in its entirety but it is a sign though
unfortunately from the Ukrainian
perspective that the
suggestion that
the Russians were running out
of these missiles is no longer the case.
and Sam,
we've also seen very intense
fighting recently
in the town of Buck move
to what's the strategic significance
since of those clashes
as far as
the Ukrainians are concerned,
they're baffled as to
why the Russians are throwing
so much
into the fight for Obama
that it doesn't
from the Ukrainian perspective
represent particularly important
strategic assets
as a target for the Ukrainians.
But if you look at
what else is going on elsewhere
in the country
with the potential,
I don't think it's yet
a counter
offensive in places like Melita
both on the Southern Front,
it does absorb a lot of Ukrainian
military energy.
The casualties on both sides
are very high around Obama.
And arguably
that is an attempt by the Russians
to make sure that the Ukrainians
can open up a counter
offensive elsewhere,
particularly in the south,
which is a very long front line.
And of course, it is
the route to the prize, really
one of the main prizes for Ukraine
which would be ultimately
to recapture the Crimean Peninsula,
which has been
illegally annexed by Russia.
And of course, we've also seen attacks
in the east of the country
with these longer
range missile strikes, potentially
signaling that the Ukrainians
may have developed
some technology
that they're not yet acknowledging,
but technology that is getting through
Russian air defenses
in the Crimean Peninsula,
in the east,
the country, and lately
in multiple bursts.